the royal family loved their country so
much they gave it their name Saudi
Arabia a bit like Kim jong-un renaming
Korea Kim jong-eun eeeh
[Music]
they cut people's heads off in public
they crucify them the mother and
Massacre and chop up Washington Post
columnist in their consulate in Istanbul
but they can do no wrong so far as the
Western governments are concerned except
perhaps things are beginning to change
not since the sopranos has there been a
family like it the capo di tutti capi is
of course the ailing elderly king of
Saudi Arabia but the real boss is the
Crown Prince MBS he has a pawn shop for
hanging his own relatives upside down in
5-star hotels and collecting the loose
change that falls from their pockets but
people thought that all that was a thing
of the past very last year but this week
MBS has rounded up still more of his own
relatives including a brother of the
king he's placed under house arrest
three of the most important Prince's in
Saudi Arabia he alleges that they were
plotting to stop him becoming the king
on the death of the elderly gentleman
now on the throne worse than not he says
they were conspiring with the United
States of America to do him in even
though he has the closest possible
relationship with Donald Trump and even
closer with Donald Trump's son-in-law
Jared Kushner a business relationship
you understand though it did bring forth
the monstrosity of the Kushner peace
plan now mercifully dead in becomed
waters but it's not just the Mafia like
intrigues inside these
the royal family that are making waves
this week their unilateral savage cut in
the price of oil caused by opening their
taps has caused shockwaves across the
world at the time of recording oil is
$33 a barrel and falling this cut has
sent shockwaves across not only other
oil producers including Britain but
caused serious problems in the economic
planning of Western countries after all
is this going to last
should you buy now well the price is at
the basement
will it fall further or will it rock it
up as it has done in the past Russia of
course is one of the losers in this
price war but Russia depends on oil it's
the second biggest oil producer in the
world for 37 percent of its annual
budget Saudi Arabia depends on oil for
87 percent of its national budget so can
the Saudi Arabians afford to bankrupt
their own economy just to serve the
interests of the United States
presumably to forestall that coup that
we were talking about Saudi Arabia under
MBS is involved in reckless wars across
the globe no more so than in their
neighboring country Yemen well they have
slaughtered more than a hundred thousand
civilians over the last five years but
where they're beginning to lose the war
just like they lost the war in Syria MBS
spent huge sums of money in Western
media and propaganda in painting himself
as a reformer well tell that to the
family of Adnan Khashoggi
the eminent journalist who was lured
into the Saudi embassy in Istanbul and
mother of their in cold blood and then
chopped into little pieces and
quite likely literally pour down the
drain keshavjee was a star columnist in
the Washington Post the leading flagship
of American journalism but even that
mother didn't spoil America's relations
with Saudi Arabia for long it's true
that women can now go to the cinema in
Saudi Arabia some of them not many even
can drive cars but this is lipstick on
the pig of Saudi royal dictatorship the
reality is on Friday afternoons when
people every Friday usually poor workers
from third-world countries have their
heads severed from their shoulders in
public life on television the capo di
tutti capi